hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast hypersecretion of
fiberglass derived exosomes during
chemotherapy promotes pancreatic cancer
chemo resistance presented by Reginald
Hill he is an Archibald assistant
professor of cancer biology at the
Department of Biological Sciences and
Harper Cancer Research Institute at
university of notre dame I'm Marjorie
Torrance of lab foods and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by libraries
labyrinth is a leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your questions into the box
that appears on the screen will answer
is many of your questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation and the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right if you're trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus is continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Reginald Hill I will now turn the
presentation over to him
thank you very much
the very kind introduction thank you to
the organizers for giving me a chance to
talk about my work today as she
mentioned I will be discussing the role
of fibroblast derived exosomes in the
prevention of chemotherapy resistance in
pancreatic cancer on the archibald
assistant professor of cancer biology at
the University of Notre Dame and so
first to start what I'd like to do is to
talk a little bit about the pancreas
basically to get people oriented on what
the organ actually does so what you're
seeing here on this slide is the
schematic showing the normal healthy
pancreas and what we can actually see is
that the pancreas is made up of three
different cell types it's mostly Astron
or cells these are the cells depicted
here by the red arrow and these are the
cells that produce all of the enzymes
that you use to break down your food and
the other major cell type of the
pancreas is the islets and the islets
produce things that people have heard
about before such as insulin and so the
insulin producing cells would be here
indicated by the red arrow in the actual
eyelids
now the minor population of cells and
the pancreas are the ductal cells
indicated by the white arrow and these
ductal cells are the cells that control
how all of these secretions and enzymes
by the pancreas are actually pushed out
into the body where they need to go to
and on the Left we can see here the
actual orientation of where the pancreas
would be the pancreas is tucked between
your stomach and duodenum both males and
females have one and it's a very small
gland that usually is very a symptomatic
on that you don't really feel and
there's no pain associated with it even
if you have a pancreatic abnormality
what we see on this slide is showing the
evolution of pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma or PDA see this is the
most dangerous and most lethal type of
pancreatic cancer that I will be talking
about today what we see normally is that
the pancreas has very thin layer of
ductal cells indicated here by the red
arrow
and you can see above and the schematic
depicting that this very thin layer of
epithelial cells is normally not very
exciting there's nothing wrong with it
and it tends to secrete the things made
by the pancreas pretty efficiently
unfortunately what will happen over time
is occasionally what will develop is a
precursor lesion or a lesion that can
give rise to pancreatic cancer called a
pancreatic intraepithelial neoplasia or
a pan and lesion as you can see here
this lesion is actually characterized by
an abnormal proliferation of ductal
cells or cells that resemble ductal
cells that begin to show an abnormal
phenotype in the pancreas and finally
the last stage the most deadly stage is
the full-blown pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma or PDA see what you can
see here in PDAC which is quite
interesting is that the actual
epithelial cancer cells depicted here by
the tip of the red arrow actually make
up the minor portion of the tumor bulk
the rest of what you actually see in
this slide here this histo pathology
staining is actually tumor
microenvironment
so all the areas out here are actually
the tumor microenvironment the field
that we actually study and what we're
actually most concerned about as it
relates to chemo resistance some
interesting facts about pancreatic
cancer is that now pancreatic cancer is
the third leading cause of cancer death
in the United States you just this year
passed breast cancer and the interesting
thing when you look at the number of
cases of cancer and the various organs
in the body is that although there are a
lot more cases of some cancers such as
lung cancer and breast cancer where you
can see almost 200,000 people will get
both lung and breast cancer every year
only about 53,000 people will get
pancreatic cancer estimated this year
however almost every single one of those
people will actually die from pancreatic
cancer so we have a disease that has a
very high mortality rate so that the
number of people who die from the
disease is almost equal to the number
it's actually going to contract a
disease itself and when we look at the
actual five-year survival rate for
pancreatic cancer compared to other
well-known cancers this gives us a
better indication about how aggressive
and deadly this disease is what we're
looking at here is the number of
patients who would be alive after five
years of being diagnosed with these
various diseases and so what most people
don't know is that pancreatic cancer has
the worst five-year survival rate of any
major cancer what we can see here is
that after five years outlined in the
red box only 7 percent of pancreatic
cancer patients would actually be alive
that's even worse than lung cancer where
you can see that 17% of these patients
would still be alive or other well known
and well studied cancers such as breast
cancer that has a 5-year survival rate
of 89% in prostate cancer that has a
5-year survival rate of 99% and so what
we're looking at here is a disease that
has a very dismal prognosis for patients
who get it and one of the reasons that
this is true is because of the late
stage in which the disease is actually
detected and so on the right side of the
slide you can see that when we look at
how the survival rate is different based
on the stage of diagnosis most patients
who have a distant metastasis is seen
here by the red arrow have only a 2%
chance of being alive five years after
surgery patients who have more of a
regional metastases are a regional
diagnosis still only have a 10% chance
of being alive after they have been
diagnosed with the disease for five
years and so this shows one of the major
problems with pancreatic cancer isn't
that it's a disease that's only detected
in its late stages and this is because
the disease is very a symptomatic most
of the time when people go into the
clinic and they complain about various
symptoms which can include back pain or
they have jaundice where they're
actually describing or in fact these
symptoms of the metastatic spread of the
disease so what you can see here is that
only about 10 to
20% of patients are actually candidates
for a surgical resection that means they
have a disease that hasn't become so
aggressive and spreads so far that a
surgeon can't actually remove it and
even with these groups of people their
five-year survival rate is still between
median survival of 10 to 20 months now
unfortunately 80% of people have what we
call unresectable tumors and these
tumors are going to be already
metastatic or they're already going to
be locally advanced and so this 80% of
patients has the worst prognosis and
that they're meeting survival will range
between 3 to 6 months or 6 to 12 months
and so part of the problem that we have
is that this disease is one that's found
far too late for surgical intervention
which still gives the best chance of
actually curing the disease and the
really scary thing about the disease is
that while it's just now becoming the
third leading cause of cancer death in
the u.s. it's projected to be the number
two leading cause of cancer death by
2020
which will be second only to lung cancer
and the reason that the number of deaths
attributed to pancreatic cancer are
projected to go up are again because of
the late stages of which we detect the
disease and the actual incidence of the
disease increasing due to a variety of
factors that you can see here on the top
of the slide including smoking obesity
poor diet family histories and the
increase in type 2 diabetes in the
country so all of this really gives us
the reason to want to really focus on
understanding how to come up with better
ways that therapeutically treat this
disease when we look at the most
commonly done treatment for pancreatic
cancer it is chemotherapy and so the
very remarkable thing about this disease
is that it's very resistant to single
agent and combination chemotherapy
gemcitabine also known as Jim czar is a
nucleoside analog that is the most
commonly given chemotherapy for
pancreatic cancer as you can see here on
the slide when gemcitabine is given to
patients who have metastatic pancreatic
cancer
the five owners are the median survival
will only be about five point nine one
months and so we know now that most
chemotherapy is not as effective alone
as it could be when given with other
agents however we don't see an added
benefit with gemcitabine in a variety of
other chemo therapies even when we look
at using gemcitabine in combination with
something like or latinum we still only
see a median survival of six point two
four months now for furin ops is a
combination of multiple types of chemo
therapies which has the largest increase
in median survival where patients will
have a median survival of 11.1 months is
depicted here however this combination
is very harsh on the patients and
therefore only people who have a
unbelievably healthy profile or even
candidates for this chemotherapy and
then it still shows a lot of chemo
resistance and then when these patients
fail well fair enough they will go back
on jump site of being based therapy that
paclitaxel and gemcitabine was really
thought to be a huge step forward for
pancreatic cancer research and patients
it was something that was hoped to
double at least the survival to patients
however we see here there is only an
eight point five month median survival
for patients who are treated with both
Matt packet Apso and gemcitabine and so
still we're at a point where we have a
remarkably chemo resistant disease that
doesn't respond to a single agent or
even combination therapy and so what
we've been trying to figure out is why
so in order to really address why this
disease is so chemo resistant we first
have to start at the beginning what do
we currently know about pancreatic
ductal adenocarcinoma we know that there
are a variety of different genetic
alterations that are found in pancreatic
cancer is depicted on this table here
Kate whereas mutations are by large the
most prevalent mutation found in
pancreatic cancer here in this chart is
showing the mutation frequency at about
58% but overall most studies would
suggest that the number of K wrasse
mutations are anywhere between 90 and 95
percent in pancreatic cancer it has one
of the tightest correlations between
single genetic event and the onset of an
actual cancer and so this was really a
very interesting thing to look at in
terms of understanding the role that the
K rath mutation may play in development
and the aggressive nature of pancreatic
cancer the K rest mutations that are
found in the majority of cases of Pedic
are actually very important because a
mutation and KS won't lock a very
important signaling pathway into its own
conformation so that what you see
usually happen is that rass which is
usually able to fluctuate between a GTP
and gdp form will be stuck in a on
activated position where a mutation in
residues 12 13 or 61 will make grass
constituent li activated so that it's
always on this leads to increased
expression of genes linked to cell
proliferation migration and
proliferation and so this was one of the
first things we knew about pancreatic
cancer is that this gene which is very
important for cells proliferating and
migrating was found to be highly
expressed in pancreatic cancer and so if
we believe that this gene is actually
very important for pancreatic cancer
development and aggressiveness how do we
actually test this what we knew at this
point was that simply this gene was
actually correlated with pancreatic
cancer but how do we actually prove this
gene or even other alterations are
actually important in causing pancreatic
cancer and what we've traditionally done
as researchers to use mouse models i've
made a variety of mouse models in my
career for both prostate cancer and
pancreatic cancer I've made so many that
I actually used the Twitter handle of
mouse mutlar so if you want to follow me
on Twitter and learn more about mouse
models or see various tweets about the
research we're doing or other research
in the field that you can you can do
that as well and so the very interesting
thing is that these mouse models allow
us to actually directly test the
function of a gene and these mouse
models are great because then we can
produce a mouse model that fully
recapitulates
the spectrum of phenotypes that we see
in the human disease we can use these
mouse models to evaluate strategies to
detect these cancers early or more
importantly come up with ways to treat
these cancers effectively and then to
translate those findings on to patients
and so what people did was to actually
create a mouse model using the mutated
version of K wrasse so what we do here
is to actually Express K rasa mutant
allele directly in the pancreas of
transgenic animals and the surprising
thing was that when we introduced this
mutant allele of K wrasse into mice
researchers found that there was only
the progression to pancreatic
intraepithelial neoplasia or panin
remember what I said earlier these are
the precursor lesions that lead up the
full-blown cancer but this is not
actually pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma itself and so we found
that these mice will very rarely and
only after a very long time progressed
to full-blown PDAC
this suggested that while these chaos
mutations were very important for
causing precursor lesions they were
actually not sufficient to give the full
spectrum of tumors that we saw in
patients so this really raised the
questions of what's missing from this
process what other events that we have
to layer on top of this event in order
to get the full spectrum of tumor
formation that we see in human patients
and this is where the ability to layer
one genetic alteration on top of another
has really benefited Mouse modelers for
a really long time and so we know there
a variety of other tumor suppressor
genes that are important in pancreatic
cancer development so even if they by
themselves don't cause pancreatic cancer
what researchers were able to show is
that these mutations or alterations when
added to an existing k Rass mutation
will give rise to full-blown PD AC and
we saw this in cases where people would
look at things like in for a loss p53
mutation tgf-beta receptor knockouts
Matt for loss and even cases of looking
at things related to snail activation
all of these events could push a
precursor lis
that's caused by care as to a more
aggressive inflammatory state into
full-blown pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma and so knowing this what
I decided to do was to take an
opportunity to look at what in
pancreatic cancer that hadn't been
looked at before might play a role in
progressing tumor development in the
context of a chaos' mutation so that's
where I looked at the status of p10 and
pancreatic cancer p10 is one of the
major tumor suppressor genes in the body
that's responsible for suppressing the
activity of things such as
phosphorylated akt and when activation
of akt is seen we know that this leads
to increased cell cycle progression and
suppressing cell death this is a major
tumor suppressor gene that's mutated or
altered in about 30 to 50 percent of all
cancers so what I wanted to really
explore was whether or not p10 played a
role in pancreatic cancer progression so
in order to actually test this what I
did was to combine an animal model that
gave us the ability to activate a mutant
allele of K wrasse and knock out p10 in
the same cells in transgenic animals so
what you're seeing here is a schematic
that depicts of that strategy and so
what we did was to have a phlox Delisle
of p10 as you can see here by the red
arrow this critical allele of p10 will
be placed between 2 loxp sites so that
meant whenever he came in contact with
career accomodates activity it would be
deleted and removed resulting in a
version of the p10 allele that doesn't
have the full functionality of the
normal p10 protein and we also added
this to the same K wrasse model that
people had already used so that what we
were able to do is to have a mutant
allele of K wrasse
it was flops or flanked by 2 loxp sites
or stop codon sorry is actually flanking
flanked by 2 loxp sites and then this
gives us the ability to knock out p10
and overexpress a mutant allele of k
Rast in the same cell so what this would
able this gave us the ability to ask the
question if we knock out
p10 which we know didn't cause
pancreatic cancer and we combine this
with a mutation and chaos which led to
precursor lesions what would be the
actual phenotype would this actually
give rise to a very aggressive tumor
that would mimic what we saw in the
human disease and the answer we got was
very surprising and very quickly that
yes it did so what we see is that this
is a mouse here on the right that
succumbed to a pancreatic cancer tumor
it's only about 14 days old and it has a
very slouched posture and in the abdomen
is kind of bulging here you can see on
the left side of the screen that the
pancreatic type mice at the normal
architecture where you can see all the
normal astronaut cells islets and
ductile cells however the mouse with
Kate wrasse activating mutation and full
loss of p10 function had a completely
just dysregulated an abnormal pancreas
where most of the Astra noir cells are
gone and we see the creation of ductal
structures and general destruction of
the normal architecture of the pancreas
unfortunately these mice actually died
before we could wean them so mice with
pancreatic cancer that developed so
quickly are unfortunately not very
useful for the types of studies we
wanted to do these mice died so fast we
couldn't really study how to prevent the
tumors from developing and so what we
needed to do was to develop a mouse
model they developed tumors using the
same genetic alterations but actually it
would develop slower over time and so in
order to do this we simply looked at the
heterozygous state of p10 as opposed to
the complete loss of p10 in this genetic
system so what we're looking at here is
a graph showing the percentage of my fat
PDAC
compared to my sub KS activation or mice
with KS activation and p10
heterozygosity and what we can actually
see is that at 3 months of age there is
about 60% of the mice have PDA see if
they have K wrasse activation in p10
heterozygosity
from
- no mice having PDA see if there K rats
only and by the time the mice are 6
months of age then we see this number
only gets higher and the mice that have
Kaos activation in Peter Harrell's agasa
T and finally at this point we see a few
mice that are just K rats only starting
to develop pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma s' this was quite
interesting as we looked at why these
tumors are forming in these mice again
we know that p10 does a big job and
suppressing the activity of
phosphorylated akt so we looked at the
precursor lesions found in both mice
that had KS activating mutation and KS
activating mutation combined with peed
in hetero zygosity what we saw is that
there was loss of p10 based on the
activity of thoughts related akt
in P back samples so we can see here in
the red arrow as immunohistochemistry
you can see the brown staining showing
that phosphorylated akt is up and the
reason that we believed it would be
higher is because of loss of p10
expression so in order to actually
confirm this we looked at the actual
tumors that develop and perform laser
capture microdissection and what this is
is that you could actually take a slide
where you have a tumor sample and using
a laser on a microscope you can cut out
a piece of this tumor and essentially do
genotyping on it to look for the
presence of wild-type
you know alleles lobster wheels or the
absence of those alleles what we
actually saw is that in these mice that
have blown pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma and virtually all these
mice showed a loss of the wild-type
allele of p10 you can see that here
depicted in the red arrow by the red box
the wild-type allele was lost in for the
5 samples that we looked at same thing
for the precursor lesions they generally
had the wild type of no presence but it
was gone by the time that these tumors
develop and this really suggested that
loss of p10 heterozygosity was important
for this progression and tumor Genesis
and so this really helped us put
together a nice story showing that p10
plays a dose-dependent role in tumor
initiation and progression
and pancreatic cancer so that if we have
K rafts combined with p10 haplin's
efficiency this will eventually give
rise to p10 loss-of-function which will
lead to pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma
so we look at our survival curve for
these different animal cohorts what we
see is that if mice have K wrasse
mutation and have normal p10 function I
indicated by this blue box here
these animals are fine they live into
adulthood they really don't develop
tumors that are lethal at all however if
we have K rats mice added with the
hetero zygosity of p10 these might start
to died about three months of age and
they're all dead by a year now as I
first showed you if we remove both
copies of p10 this dramatically shifts
the survival curve so that these animals
depicted by the red line here will
actually die their disease before we
could even wean them these animals died
before you know 20 days of age so what
we've shown is that p10 is a very
important gatekeeper in preventing the
development of very lethal tumor
development and the pancreas and so this
was quite interesting as it related to
how p10 may play a role in the
progression of pancreatic cancer in a
mouse what we really wanted to do was to
actually explore how this could play a
role in human cancer and so in
collaboration with surgeons at UCLA what
we performed was a comprehensive
bioinformatic analysis of human patients
to figure out which pathways in which
level of regulation was important for
preventing patients from developing
lethal tumors so what we examined were
recepticle tumors so these are the
tumors of patients who came into the
clinic early enough to have their tumor
samples actually collected and then what
we did was to do an array profiling
looking at micro rna's RNA and snip
analysis to determine which pathway
alteration separated these patients a
good or poor prognosis so it's a saying
patients who did well and live longer
what were their genetic profile why
compared to patients who came quicker to
their actual disease and what we saw is
that the p10 pathway and in this case
through microarray I'm sorry through
micro RNA alterations were responsible
for separating these patients into good
and poor prognosis so this really
combined nicely what the data that we
have from the mouse model because what
we could see is that the mouse model
that we generated looking at KS
activation and p10 heterozygosity
actually did a great job of
recapitulating the pathology of the
human disease so that the mouse and both
the human samples look the same but more
importantly on a genetic level we had
data showing that p10 suppression of
tumor development was the thing that led
to people either having a good or a poor
prognosis so if you were a mouse and you
had p10 fully functional you live really
far you know long life as opposed to
mice that did not have p10 function and
this was the same in the humans humans
that had p10 functional had a better
prognosis compared to humans whose
tumors had a loss of p10 function so
this really again cemented the role of
p10 in this process of suppressing tumor
development that was a good start for
our model but what we needed to do then
was to address a major hallmark of
pancreatic cancer and that is
inflammation inflammation plays a
critical role in cancer progression and
a variety of different sites we know
that lots of sites of cancer will arise
from areas of chronic irritation
infection and inflammation and by the
age of 70 approximately 40% of patients
with hereditary pancreatitis will have
been diagnosed with pancreatic cancer so
as we see depicted in this schematic
here we know the risk of cancer is
actually going to increase because of
inflammation so what we wanted to look
at is the role of cyclooxygenase - or
Cox - this is the key mediator of
inflammation in the body inflammation
goes through a couple of different
pathways there's a couple of different
forms of cyclooxygenase Cox 1 which is a
constitutive the active form of this
enzyme and Cox 2 which is an inducible
form and so things such as non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs something as
simple as aspirin this will actually
target cops to this inducible form
what we had seen in a lot of different
places is that cops to expression just
like K wrasse mutations were very
prevalent in pancreatic cancer so what
we wanted to show is whether cops to you
over expression on its own could
actually cause pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma I'm not going to show you
that data now out of the interest of
time but we don't actually see that
tumors occur when you just have coffee
over expression but that raised the
question of do you have the ability to
show that this inflammation driven by
cops too will actually lead to increased
tumor Genesis in an existing mouse model
such as the one that I described earlier
and in fact it does so what we're
looking at here is a chart showing the
comparison of tumor phenotype advice
that have just the K rest activating
mutation and p10 heterozygosity
compared to the mice that have K wrasse
activating mutation p10 heterozygosity
and inflammation is indicated by Cox 2
over expressions seen here well you can
see here on the right of the graph is
that the mice with Cox you over
expression have even more an earlier 2
or development in our previous mouse
model so again the earlier mouse model
got tumors pretty quickly that around 3
months of age what we're looking at here
is a one to two month window of time and
we see that they're already full-blown
pancreatic duct grando carcinomas that
are formed and these mice that have cost
you over expression now the really
exciting thing is when we look at the
actual pathology of these tumor sections
under the microscope we see something
very remarkable when we look at the mice
at this stage we see that the mice of K
wrasse activation and peach and hetero
zygosity have precursor lesions and a
little bit of ductal structure forming
you compare this to what we see in the
mice macaques you overexpression at it
they have full-blown PDAC
you can see the epithelial cell is
marked by the red arrow there but more
importantly they have this massive Vesna
pleasure what this is is the tumor
microenvironment that's surrounding the
cancer cells as I mentioned earlier the
remarkable thing about pancreatic cancer
is that this tumor microenvironment
makes up about 90
of the tumor bulk a better way of seeing
that is perhaps depicted here when we
look at Mason's trichrome staining and
what this actually detects is collagen
deposition by fibroblast and what we can
see in that these mice that have Cox
tree overexpression have very robust
collagen deposition the starts even at
the earliest stages in the panin or
precursor stage and it's very robust
when we have the full-blown pancreatic
ductal carcinoma a lot more so than what
we see when these mice just have chaos
activation and p10 heterozygosity and so
this does Malaysia is very important in
that this fully recapitulates what we
see in the human disease when I showed
these lives to pathologists they were
like that's it these are the ones that
actually resemble the pancreatic cancer
that we see in human patients and so
were able to show that our mouths with
cops to driven tumor growth really
mimics that doesn't a pleasure that we
see in the human condition so the
interesting thing again is that we
compared the pan into the PD AC you can
see on the yellow arrows here that
yellow arrow is pointing to the stroma
or the tumor microenvironment fibroblast
layer in the normal cells and in the
actual tumors compare that again to what
we see in the actual human sample so
that we have a lot more decimal place in
the humans than we see in most cancer
the more importantly our mouse model
actually mimics this very guy nice that
which says that we can look at the role
that inflammation plays and more
importantly the role that fibroblasts
play in making these tumors worse or
possibly chemo resistant a lot of times
and people talk about how you know
there's a route to a problem and cancer
it might be something related to cancer
stem cells or resistant populations of
epithelial cells I'd like to think about
what the tumor microenvironment all
these fibroblast represents and again
here this is trichrome staining to where
we see all this deposition of collagen
by fiberglass this creates a soil that
these cancer cells actually grow in and
so I think of this is not getting to the
root of the problem with the soil of the
problem that's what we have the bigger
issue the tumor micro
environment itself is what we have to
focus on in order to figure out how to
make significant progress in treating
this disease one of the things we looked
at we looked at patient timbres was what
happens to them when they're actually
treated with either saline or
chemotherapy like him sighted me what
we're looking at here is the
proliferation index by i8c so this
marker ki-67 well stain the nuclei of
cells that are proliferating positively
what you can see here is that the
epithelial cells are present and they're
polluting their are lots of little brown
dots you can see in a variety of these
cells and so the interesting thing to me
was that when we treated these patients
these tumors with gemcitabine we saw
that the number of epithelial cells
actually went down there's a lower
percentage of epithelial cells overall
here and you'll see that these
epithelial cells actually have a Laurel
efficient index or not I'm showing as
many prep Brown nuclei understanding
Polly devor ki-67 however the thing that
didn't seem to change was the tumor
microenvironment
so these fibroblasts were here just is
prominently or even more so than they
were before the tumors are actually
treated so to me that raised a very
interesting question question being why
are these stromal cells these
fibroblasts still here if we are
successfully removing the epithelial
cells and not the stromal cells might
this suggest that the stromal cells
themselves might be responding to
chemotherapy differently and then they
might actually be resistant to the drugs
themselves and so what we wanted to do
was to examine the role the fibroblasts
compared to epithelial cells the
fibroblasts depicted here by these
little triangle or these little diamonds
people that examine the role of normal
fibroblasts as they interact with normal
cancer cells or normal or tumor cells or
the role in cancer associated
fibroblasts with normal epithelial cells
and tumor cells and so what we
specifically wanted to address was how
chemotherapy when it's hitting these
fibroblasts that are associated with
tumors how is it actually affecting the
tumor cell and so this isn't really what
our
he really focused on and so what we
wanted to know are is it possible that
chemotherapy resistance can actually
come through factors secreted by cancer
associated fibroblast and this can
actually have an effect on the role or
the ability of epithelial cells to
actually resist the chemotherapy they're
exposed to and so what we actually did
was to take media from fibroblasts that
we had already previously found to be
resistant to chemotherapy and so when we
found these fireblast fibroblasts were
resistant to chemotherapy what we wanted
to do is to see if they could actually
help support the role or the growth of
epithelial cells that were you know
sensitive to chemotherapy so we grew
these fibroblasts which we got from a
collaborator at any Ana University in
Indianapolis we grew them and we took
the media from these fibroblasts and we
isolated it and put it on to L three
point six pancreatic cancer cells and
these pancreatic cancer cells are
actually sensitive to chemotherapy like
some cited being so when they're treated
with them site I mean they'll actually
die so what we saw was that when we
simply added the media from the cancer
associated fibroblasts to these L three
point cells you can see here the purple
bars we had a greater number of cells
proliferating so the control that we
used here was just the L three point six
cells added their media add for
themselves so we can see is that the
number of cells that were alive was
higher when we use trypan blue counting
or even an MP T proliferation I say the
most important thing happened when we
actually took this media and added it to
L 3.6 cells and then treated them with
chemotherapy so what we saw here is that
the media from the CAF's
enhance the ability of these L 3.6 cells
to survive exposure to chemotherapy so
this was what was really exciting
because it showed that there is
something that's secreted by these
fibroblasts it can actually keep cancer
cells alive and keep them from dying
when exposed to chemotherapy and so what
we
to do was to determine what that factor
might be or more importantly how it
might actually be released from these
cancer associated fibroblast this is
what we came upon exosomes so exosomes
are very exciting molecules or delivery
vectors that people are looking at right
now
Nexus ohms are very small lipid vesicles
between you know 30 and 100 nanometers
in size and they're secreted from cells
and they contain a lot of different
things including micro rna's rnase DNA
and protein they can travel long
distances in serum an interesting thing
that we'd seen is that cancer cells
secreted more exercise than normal cells
so what we really wanted to figure out
is how these exosomes might be playing a
role in the ability of calves to
transfer factors that might promote
chemo resistance in cells that uptake
them so what we did was to label a
cancer associated fibroblast cell line
with gfp so we uses the CD 63 gfp
labeled cell line that we create in CD
63 is a marker of exosomes so what we
saw is that when we looked at the normal
level of GFP expression in fibroblasts
we saw a very you know mild low level of
GFP staining however when we increase
the amount of gemcitabine we added a lot
of times I had been to these calves the
amount of fluorescent staining that we
saw was greatly increased so that the
total fluorescence seemed to go up
dramatically in these cells we were able
to actually quantify that looking at
corrected total fluorescence so that the
number of GFP positive signal that we
got went up a lot in the cells that were
treated with gemcitabine in order to
actually show that a little bit more
quantitative manner we use a nano site
to actually measure the exosomes that
were released by the cells and this is
what we came across a very interesting
finding what we see is that the cancer
cells whether there are the pancreatic
cells that are epithelial in nature will
have exosome secretion that will
increase when they're treated with
gemcitabine here depict it as GT which
means Jim treated compared to
non-treated however the wild-type
fibroblast or the cancer associated
fiberglass both had a lot more exosome
secretion or exosome hypersecretion when
they were treated with gemcitabine so
this was quite interesting so what this
showed was that fibroblast more so than
cancer cells had a very accelerated rate
of exosome release following exposure to
chemotherapy so what we wanted to look
at then was what happens to cells that
take up these exosomes that have been
exposed to chemotherapy and they've been
released by these fibroblasts and so
what we looked at was the proliferation
in these cell lines that had received
these Jim therapy treated calf derived
exosomes and we saw in these drug
resistant cell lines the tank one in the
asp cell line that both of these cell
lines had an increase in cell number
following exposure to exosomes from
these fibroblasts that had been exposed
to gemcitabine and more importantly this
increased the ability of these cells who
survived chemotherapy the thing that was
most impressive was that we got the most
dramatic effect in these cells that had
the gemcitabine treatment and were given
CAF's that came from our sorry the
capsid CAD the fibroblasts and these
cells were the ASP c1 cells so this is
our metastatic pancreatic cancer cell
line so what we see here is that the
calves give this metastatic cell line
the most protection and this cell is
drug resistant as well and so what we
see in patients when they come into the
clinic is that this is the type of tumor
that they will have will be metastatic
you know already to be resistant inside
of being and so compared to the ability
of these cells own exosomes to confer
resistance utam side of being the calf
derived exosomes had an even greater
impact on allowing these cells to
actually survive which is probably a
very important clinical finding and so
having shown that these exosomes seem to
play a very important role in giving
these cells the ability to survive
chemotherapy exposure what we wanted to
do was to figure out how to actually
block this exosome release or secretion
so
identified a inhibitor as Fingal Meissen
asus gw4 869 this inhibits exosome
release from cells so we're able to show
is that using a trans well system where
we cultured the fibroblast in the upper
level of the dish and the epithelial
cells in the bottom portion of the dish
we were able to show that we could
inhibit the release of exosomes from
these fibroblast by using GW 46:9 what
you're looking at on the right is the
quantitation of this effect and so
normally when we treat these fiber
blasters inside of main we get a nice
induction of exosome release if looked
comparing the red bar to the black bar
however when we treat with GW 46:9 even
the presence of gemcitabine we don't see
that increase in exosome secretion
anymore so we're blocking about 80 to
90% of the exosome secretion with the
treatment of these cells with GW 4 8 6 9
and so what we wanted to do then was to
figure out if blocking the exosome
release from these calves would actually
alter that ability that I just talked
about earlier the ability of these calf
derive exosomes
to increase human resistance in the
epithelial cells and that's actually
what we saw so compared again here the
exosomes from the AFP see one cells when
we give these cells exosomes from calves
they have higher chemo resistance
comparing the white bar to the red bar
however when we treat these calves with
GW 46:9 and block the exosome secretion
then we're actually decreasing their
ability to enable this to more
resistance we're doing a partial rescue
here of this effect which is very
exciting this shows that by simply
blocking the episome release were able
to take away this protective effect that
the calves are providing for the
epithelial cells this really raised the
question of could we actually study this
in vivo how would this consequence
actually play out if we're able to block
the ability of exosomes and fibroblasts
to support chemo resistance a tumor cell
growth in a natural mouse model and so
previously we had looked at this and our
in vitro system using trends well as a
system but not what we wanted to do was
combine these fibreglass and that poppy
lleol cells together in the natural
situation where they would normally
exist where they're actually coal
cultured and grown together so what we
did was to take mice and inject them
with a mixture of epithelial cells and
fibroblasts and plant this into the
myself cutaneous Lee and let this grow
for two weeks
and then you can see depicted on the
schematic we would eject with either
regular chemotherapy or chemotherapy and
GW 46:9 to block out to some release and
then measure tumor survival or sorry
tumor growth in these animals what we
actually saw is that when you look at
the red line these are the untreated
mice compared to the gray the treated
mice with just gemcitabine whereas Jim
cited being you compare rat to grey
doesn't actually show any effect on the
tumor growth of these mice after 10 days
when we use Jim site of being in
combination with GW 46:9 now we have
significant decrease in tumor size
compared to the untreated control so
whereas gemcitabine alone doesn't
actually significantly alter tumor size
once we add the ability to block a Qasim
release in this in vivo experiment we
have successfully blocked tumor growth
to a significant degree and so at this
point we determined that using them
cited main treatment would cause the
hypersecretion of exosome some calves
this will lead to increased
proliferation and drug resistant and
epithelial cells and by using GW 46:9
blocking exosome hypersecretion we could
inhibit this process we still didn't
know at this point was what was the
actual mechanism that's responsible for
this and so in order to really try to
figure that out what we did was to
perform a study where we characterized
the micro rna's that were found in the
exosomes of calf when they've been
treated either with gemcitabine without
gemcitabine or when they were not cancer
associated fibroblasts at all as you can
see here depict in the schematic and
what
we identified were micro rna's that were
differentially regulated in these
different situations and this was a
study that was funded by the Indiana
CTSI and so what we did was to come up
with a list of microRNAs that were being
released by these calves when they were
treated with chemotherapy and then to
look at the targets of these micro rna's
and to figure out which ones might most
closely associate with things like poor
prognosis and pancreatic cancer so we've
developed a shortlist of 5 micro RNA as
you can see here on this table
there were all significantly increased
by a full changing wear of 2.5 to 4.6
fold increase in the calf that had been
treated with gemcitabine so these were
actually the micro rna's that were
enriched in the calf's that have been
treated with chemotherapy and the
interesting thing that we found and why
we like this shortlist is because all
these actually were mirrors that
actually targeted p10 so what you're
seeing here is their score showing how
closely they or tightly they regulate
p10 funkin so we found it interesting
again that from our earlier studies
we've shown that p10 was a very
important regulator of tumor growth or
aggressiveness in the pancreas and that
all these mirrors these micro RNAs
targeted p10 and so what this really
suggested hypothesis was that these
calves were really aiding the epithelial
cells by suppressing p10 function giving
them the ability to activate a variety
of different cell survival signals so
that's true it should mean that we
should be able to look at these tumors
that we treated in these mice and see a
p10 change associated with this exosome
release and that's actually what we saw
so we look at the mice that had been
treated with gemcitabine they grew very
quickly and they had very low p10
expression however when we looked at the
mice that had been treated with
gemcitabine ngw for 8 6 9 what we see is
that not only that this treatment
actually restore p10 function but it
also again was the one that actually
shrank the tumors are called
mr. grow to the least amount so again
this really was it's kind of explained
our finding that the exosomes are
probably targeting p10 function and that
that's how they're actually contributing
to this result so we looked at whether
or not we could simply deplete the
exosomes
to get the same effect again kind of
more proof of principle of our
hypothesis and so what we're seeing here
on the top left is that these exosomes
from calves when added to a SP c1 cells
they suppress p10 expression however we
deplete the calf's media for exercise
you can basically just spin out the
excess on segregation and then add that
to the SPC one cells then the amount of
peach expression goes back up same thing
with the ell 3.6 cells again this is the
drug sensitive cell line will receive
the exact same effect where when we look
at on the right side the calves that are
then you take their excess ohms and add
it to the L 3.6 cells we see decreased
p10 expression we deplete the exosomes
from the media and the p10 expression
goes back up on the bottom portion of
the screen what you see are the
Associated Western blots that we did for
that as well
so again showing that cast with AF P c1
cells show a decrease in p10 expression
when we deplete the exosomes from the
media of caste we see that go back up
and on the right what we're showing the
el 3.6 cells is that phosphor min akt
expression correlates with that in the
way that we would expect so that when we
incubate these el 3.6 cells with calf
derived exosomes we see an increase in a
kt expression and this decrease this
decreases when we do the exosome
depletion from the media itself we
decided to quickly kind of explore the
ability of the top hit that we had near
90 to a to carry out this process so we
developed a cell line where we could
over express mere 90 to a so we use the
Emir 90 to a mimic that we can get
robust over expression in mere 92 a
picked it by the graph on the left side
of the screen on the right you can see
that will be overexpress it's near 92 a
mimic we knock down
expression pretty nicely and so what we
saw is that when we look at the
expression of mere 92 a in the
environments that we first identify this
effect in when we have calves that are
incubated with a FPC one sells these ASP
c1 cells show an increase in mere 92 a
expression is depicted by the red arrow
and this is true in the ASP c1 cells and
also in our drug sensitive el 3.6 cells
and when we look at the expression of
mere 92 a in the GW treated calves it
decreases as well and so we're showing
here again that this mere 92 a seems to
be probably what's one of the key micro
rna's responsible for suppressing p10
function in this system and so what we
have been able to show so far with our
proposed mechanism is that the inside of
beam will cause the hypersecretion of
exosomes that these exosomes will have a
high amount of micro rnas at target p10
and this this decrease in p10 will lead
to an increase in proliferation and
chemo resistance and so our kind of
major findings are that these jim-jim
site of being treated CAF's are very
important and helping to transfer the
ability of chemo resistant to recipient
epithelial cells and that this role is
really mediated very large part by micro
RNAs and that by inhibiting the exosome
signaling as we've been able to do with
GW 46:9 or through after some depletion
we've been able to suppress tumor growth
and chemo resistance and our in vitro
and in vivo experiments so when we look
at how old this really ties together my
lab has looked at a variety of different
ways to explain how the tumor
microenvironment is responsible for
driving progression of pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma one of the things I did
not have time to talk about today was
the role of in a plasma particular
stress or stress and how that affects
chemo resistance also something is
driven by the micro environment and
we've identified a compound that can
actually suppress ER stress and this is
something that we've helped to get
orphan drug designation for
and we're moving forward with that in
clinical trials we also know that the
tumor microenvironment plays an
important role in the ability of cancer
cells to metastasize and to spread to
other organs that we've identified a
molecule NTS s one that stabilizes the
ability of these tumor cells to leave
their location and hopefully that will
give us the ability to prevent the
amount of metastatic cells that are
found in patients when I talk to you
today most about was the excellent
hypersecretion we know that the tumor
microenvironment these fibroblasts
specifically produce a high amount of
exosomes that these are released to give
rise to a variety of different
phenotypes including increased
proliferation and increased chemo
resistance and that's the paper by kate
richards my Gradstein that came out
earlier this year and one thing I don't
have a lot of time to talk about but I
wanted to mention is that we know these
exercises can be very important for a
variety of different things these
exercise again are very small they're
found in all solutions in the body and
they travel a long distance and so these
exosomes contain micro rna's which are
great biomarker for cancer and so one of
the projects we've done in collaboration
with engineers at Notre Dame is to look
at how this might be very useful for
early detection so that's a study that
we've already published which is an
engineering group on campus I just want
to take a couple of minutes to wrap up
and show a few slides about our early
detection of pancreatic cancer again
since this is a major problem that we
face with wive's disease are so
aggressive so what we've collaborated
with this group on is to figure out a
way to use the information inside
exosome these micro RNAs for early
detection of pancreatic cancer and we do
this by developing a microfluidic chip
that will lyse exosomes and release
their contents and these micro rna's
will then be bound to a membrane sensor
and this students the ability to
actually use these micro RNAs as
biomarkers so that we could detect
pancreatic cancer earlier than we've
ever been able to before one of the
biggest problems of why pancreatic
cancer so aggressive that there are
currently no standard screening
protocols for it now there's nothing
like you know mammograms or other things
that are done for you know prostate
cancer and so
part of the reason we really want to
push this type of projects is because we
need to figure out a way to detect the
disease as early as possible and again
that's how the mouse model can actually
help we know when mouse models get
precursor leads we know when they get
tumors so we can use our animal models
to show the usefulness of using the ex
assemble micro rna's for early detection
of pancreatic cancer we can treat these
mice with chemicals different chemo
therapeutic agents and to look for the
decrease in expression of our biomarkers
and these excess ohm's again to give us
not only diagnostic information but
prognostic information as well to help
to treat patients better and more
effective than we've been able to do and
so with that I'd like to end and thank
the grad students in the lab undergrads
who do the work my collaborators at
Notre Dame and other Institute's and our
funding sources I'll be happy to take
any questions
thank you dr. hill for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window type your questions into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button
well answer is many of your questions we
have time for let's get started our
first question is is the exosome
hypersecretion seen only with
gemcitabine treatment
yeah the question
is this only gemcitabine based that's a
great question we first looked at
gemcitabine because of the role that
plays and being the predominant
chemotherapy given in pancreatic cancer
but we started to look at other
compounds as well including that
paclitaxel which again is the
combination therapy that's most
currently now given in pancreatic cancer
and we found that the exosome
hypersecretion is in fact caused by
almost every agent that we can find
including that paclitaxel and so what it
seems to be is that it's not a Jim site
of being specific response it's a
response to chemotherapy or in general
any type of insulin or stress to the
cell that causes it to hyper secrete
exosomes and so how similar those
exosomes say from that paclitaxel
compared to subside to be maybe is
something that we're currently studying
our next question is do these X's ohm's
affect all cells the same way
that was a very interesting thing that
we have to think about since we know
that all cells secrete exosomes normal
cells healthy cells secrete them as well
so we've seen that the genetic makeup of
the cell that receives the exosomes will
play an important role in that response
so chaos mutations are found in most
pancreatic cancer cells but there are
some pink rounded cancers that don't
have chaos mutations and we saw that
those cells don't have a boost in chemo
resistance from these fibroblast derived
exosome so it seems to suggest that not
all cells will respond to these exosome
in the same way and we're still not
clear how transformative exosome from
the calf can be we're still early and
looking at how normal cells might
actually be transformed to full-blown
cancer cells by these exosome but yes so
far our data suggests that there are
very different response depending on the
nature of the cells thank you for that
answer our next question is what about
epithelial cell axons do they play a
role in this process
yes we
want to understate the importance of the
epithelial exosomes
we know that they are there especially
in our in vivo experiment where we're
combining the fibroblasts and the
epithelial cells together we know that
the UW for 869 is inhibiting release of
exosomes from both the fibroblast and
the epithelial cells what we saw in our
in vitro analysis and force I didn't
have time to show this data is that the
cancer associated fibroblasts their
protective effect seems to be higher
even than the effect that exosomes from
drug-resistant cancer cells actually
have and so we know that the cancer cell
exosomes are important that's why we use
those X's ohm's as a control for all of
our experiments but it's just that the
fibroblasts arrive that because some
seem to be more potent in their effect
Berlin has to do with some other
intrinsic value these episomes have
compared to the epithelial exomes what
we're interested in but we do know that
they have an effect so we're not we
can't conclusively say we would ever
want to say that the exercise of
epithelial cells don't matter because
they do but we just see more potent
effect from our fibroblast derived
exosomes okay we have time for one more
question do proteins and exosomes matter
for chemo resistance
that's one of the things that we are
investigating through another project in
the lab as I mentioned earlier exosomes
contain micro rna's RNA DNA and protein
we focus initially on micro rna's
because micro rna's are what's enriched
in exosomes we do know that the proteins
play a very important role so what we
did was a similar type of analysis where
we performed mass spec on the exosomes
from fibroblasts that were treated with
chemotherapy or not and looked at the
profile of proteins that we found inside
and there definitely is some overlap in
terms of the pathways but it seems to be
a very unique pathway also that seems to
be more important for how the XSL
proteins actually play a role in chemo
resistance and so it's again a
fascinating field to look at how what's
packaging in exosome might matter so we
definitely are exploring in other
studies the role of proteins as well but
we definitely believe they will play an
important role as well I would like to
once again thank dr. Reginald Hill for
his presentation I would also like to
thank lab roots for making today's
educational web cats possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through January of
2017 you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please sure
that announcements with your colleagues
who may have missed today's flight event
that's all for now we thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon goodbye